[Music]  [Applause]  oh  [Music]  erica you haven't ever wished a family  would adopt you  have you nope  anybody who choose me would be pretty  unusual  we'll take this one for the first time  in my life i'm being made to do  something i don't want to do  now then let's you and i get a few  things straight  my name is bella yaga i'm a witch  great you agree that you'll teach me  magic  and i agree to help you out if you work  really hard  i shall do anything to hurt you  i love potion for the boy next door all  of these are pretty  useless to me the spell i believe you're  looking for  is somewhere towards the back hang on  you actually talk  of course i do just not very often  in this household there's one rule  that's crucial  you must on no account for any reason  ever  dare disturb the man drake don't be rude  can only be filled by a witch  i'll be learning magic well so i was  told can't wait to start  [Music]  you